hi guys today I'm back with another game
for you and we're going to be playing
Sarah is missing see if I can find this
missing girl but before we start I won't
let you know that this video is a
collaboration with a company called easy
SMX who sell a lot of gaming gadgets and
techy stuff they have been nice enough
to offer us a giveaway for one of their
gaming headsets so if you want to be in
for the chance of winning a new headset
and sauron christmas so you know if you
don't need one you can always give it
away to a friend stick around at the end
of the video to find out how you can be
part of that give away i'm currently
using one of their awesome gaming mouses
and it's here flushing away on my desk
looks pretty frickin snazzy and if you
like that as well there will be a link
in the description for you to get
discount off that without further ado
let's stop talking about promotions and
just get on the game and on bit late on
this so i do apologize but it really did
stick out to me because it just seems
like a really unique idea and you guys
know how much I love my indie games that
anything that's like a little bit
different from the norm so I wanted to
play this because it's all on a phone
and I think you're kind of going through
oh maybe this is sarah's phone then your
device run into a problem and needs to
be set do you want to restore your
device into an earlier time yeah go
through oh is this your phone and then
you realize that it was a girls who was
missing before it was yours oh I don't
um let's play the game stop talking
restoring iris I used to work in a
company called iris they were an
advertising company you don't appear to
be so I have we met I don't know I
haven't been reading I was just like
freaking out my heart going so fast
right now let me turn skim down ah I
don't want to play anymore I don't play
anymore I will play Oh flame welcome
back stara this phone appears to be
damaged and you don't appear to be sorry
have we met I don't think so although I
don't know who you are oh oh okay I was
just typing like didn't of it um who is
Sarah sorry young is the rightful owner
of this phone please return it to her
she's very pretty girl hi sorrow oh it's
not it's not video okay well she is
she's pretty I can be I can be your
sorry if you want no no mmm um I wish I
could but how I try and do but it's my
phone now I want my verizon want to give
a bad to her based on your response I
just assume she's not with you I don't
even know who she I asked you who saw
her was this person where he needs to
put their phone on charge the red bar
bugs me and I will need to put it on
charge it seems at the last video she
took implies that she's in danger would
you like to watch it and help me verify
let's see what you got
[Music]
why would you send him that video
instead of calling the cops this is the
only file left at this moment the rest
of the content seems to be deleted or
intentionally damaged how much can you
fix it appears that only fourteen point
three percent of this device is
operational hmm she looks like she needs
help yes it would be it would appear to
be say I am this mobile as personal
assistant oh is that who you are I
thought assaulting to someone like a
friend or something and it is in my best
interest to locator and it would be good
being your good conscience to help you
find it so it's like Siri but in the
future series actually gonna be helpful
actually gonna care about you that's
cute um why do you want me to help why
do you care yeah yeah do you actually
care she's my owner Oh cute little a I
um I want to make sure she's safe it's
my prime directive you sound human I
want to find out about this AI yes I
want to be human you want a body we are
wasting precious time here we had me
fine so yeah yeah go on anita was tour
as much of this contents of this phone
as I'm able to please press the back
button then tap and hold anywhere on the
home screen what was that that just came
up goodbye love you okay others she is I
[Music]
believe I can recover some of this
phone's data yeah yeah yeah do it I'm
really confused about what happened at
the beginning of the game cuz that took
me by surprise could you tell i bring it
out um
okie dokie Oh messages hey James a buddy
hey buddy she got a buddy okay there's a
lot of people here does anyone look well
he buddy at she looks like really scary
he's just peering through like hey sorry
I was a trip it was terrible oh why was
that aah Derek broke up with me when I
was younger I don't know why but I
always liked the name Derek he saw a
little stories up okay where is this
curry so idea by the way free this week
oh no he's a definite freak leave body
alone no I'm pretty busy I've got this
final thesis to deliver what is it about
do you really want to know buddy do you
really what I remember yeah sure I'm
doing a research in relativity of ghosts
a culture that's so cool and how it
transcends from verbal tales handed down
through the generations to a digital and
cyberspace hauntings I knew he was
creepy by the way are you into blood
stuff I hate guys like you're trying to
open up to someone and they just say
weird stuff I gotta go buddy and no even
if I am you're not it no problem perky
lady a friend desperately trying to
crawl all the way out of the friend zone
but they don't realize that they're just
putting themselves in their father
brilliant um buddy you're strange who
should we talk to you next who took less
autumn okay Derek Oh is her boyfriend Oh
secrets gossip gossip hey you there what
do you want and nothing I just i'm i'm
bout to board why should I care well
that's one of the problems is it you
barely care did you text me to tell me
that you're such an [ __ ] look I
didn't mean to hurt you I definitely did
want to hurt you I mean I wish things
were different I don't want us to end I
guess that's what I'm trying to say
I'm trying to tell you that this was how
I plan things to be this is not higher
plan things to be things ended when you
left you left you and your planning
enough plans you plan and plan but you
never do anything all you do is run and
work and use your work as an excuse to
avoid confronting the issue I think you
just described yourself why do you
always do this and you keep blaming my
work for our problems stop blaming [ __ ]
on me and these girls naked or not they
are not our problems it's me and you and
you're the one that keeps avoiding this
[ __ ] shifting problems here and there so
what does he do like take pictures of
naked girls or does he work in a strip
club oh she is angry I can't believe you
decided to do this not that I [ __ ]
celebrated but it's Valentine's Day who
the [ __ ] leaves a girlfriend to fly back
to another country to photograph nude
women he is a nude photographer on
Valentine's Jesus and not have the balls
to tell me about it you lying piece of
[ __ ] not telling you something is not
the same as lying I told you it's a
last-minute gig it's a fashion shoot
babe let's get that straight you want to
play technicality with me now you
[ __ ] serious go away don't just go
away you're good at that at least that's
one damn thing that you're good at just
go you there hey I'm borden out take
care sorry bye hey how are you it's been
a while ah bloody oh um hey baby I took
talk to me please i'm so sorry i miss
you oh my god she ignored him for so
long so long what are you up to sorry
talk to me please baby I'm not your baby
stop texting me I need to move on ok got
it bye Sarah oh so it's so sad let's
talk to her mom moms always make things
better hi mom just wanted to check in oh
that's look cute I need to do that more
often my mom usually text me and then I
just kind of forget to text box I'm an
awful daughter and Derek and I have
decided to end things things were not
working outside but I'm like
sorry to hear that Sarah but I've always
known that Derek could never keep up
with you best you ended things before it
got too serious moms always and that's
like he wasn't good enough for you and I
always knew he wasn't good enough for
you what time is your flight back I
could have my driver pick you up from
the airport cute she has a driver mmm
right well mum actually don't panic I've
decided to say sorry I don't understand
you've just come out of a relationship
and you're in a foreign land why would
you want to say I need some time for
myself mum being at home now just I can
what do you mean you can you get on the
plane and come home mum no I can't I've
canceled the flight ticket ready anyway
why the world would you do something so
stupid as that Sarah mum listen so you
come home this in this intent I will get
my assistant to buy you a new ticket
right now she's rich hey I'm she's rich
ok so blah blah I can't read all these
so I've scheduled to meet the executive
creative director of lloyd irvin the
advertising agency at noon tomorrow
don't embarrass me whoa her mom is like
crazy businesswoman you're really going
to pick up your silly research and
ghosts and things ok so her mom doesn't
like that she researches ghosts she
thinks it's not so she wants her to
change her career path whoa she's being
mean how are you going to pay the Bears
with this kind of career path bloody
hell it's it's my parents you will have
dinner at home we will take father on
this ok bye mum whoa Jesus okay um let's
see what the cuny group oh okay chattin
available never mind faith I need a
favor you always need a favor what's new
Oh mean hey don't be mean I really go
just gathering unique mean a party I'm
not really up for it but it's just sort
of thing too what do you mean it's while
/ good Nash Nash Nash what is that the
witches feast how is that my thing
you're the pagan hey I follow you to
charge your right was a big deal
supernatural stuff I don't party with
ghosts I'm going to fall for one of your
conventions again face I'm not going to
fall okay so she was invited to a party
we've
since you said no but then she was like
ask me again later so maybe she did go
and it's a weird pianist convention
perhaps you're not normally like this oh
hey bootylicious you all gay feeling
like the dumps come join me in some ABS
at the club sorry babe got an assignment
can this girl honestly sounds like me to
all of my friends come out tonight no I
can I just don't leave me alone skip it
babes they have abs like like like abs
like thi lam oh love Tyler I know I
won't want to miss hanging out with you
guys but some other time it's ladies
night and beside we get ice cream you
need a break tempting right I'm gonna
pass and so she didn't go out with them
don't ever do it watch your calories
haha bet bet bet bet what is this girl
no they love my love handles then
puppies world mama hey where you been oh
okay this must have been when she when
she started going missing heard you went
out with faith last night oh I tried to
call you but I couldn't get through I'm
worried okay so she went out with faith
so she did go to that pagan istic thing
okay we're we're piecing it together
derek is a douche buddy is weird she
went to a pagan istic thing with faith
um he was Joe her mom doesn't like her
choice and ghosts oh I so annoying i'm
so over him forget him sorry you're on
your own now we have our ups and downs
that's normal I guess you're right you
are the genius in our batch go meet a
crazy friend tried dating app you never
know I don't know how to make friends I
already have one crazy friend don't
think I can handle another if I meet
someone interesting and usually just buy
them a drink and take them home not too
sure about dating apps sometimes I can't
tell if you're joking but go put
yourself out there go have a
conversation with someone at a cafe or
something a party might not be a bad
idea um okay so maybe this is why she
went to that party that faith invited
her to because Jill's like just do it
just do something crazy good
I hope you save lots of lives out there
oh I think she's gonna have to do some
charity work that's cute oh she's a cute
friend oh yeah she definitely is doing
something like that okay James you're
the last one coffee six o'clock yeah
sure let's make it's exciting 630 is
bring the stuff I gave you Oh next time
bring your own we touch okay so she must
be working with him on the ghost stuff
cool study buddy unless I'm look oh oh
don't do that to me unfortunately Zafar
stopped working please contact the
developer for more information let's
read her mail buddy hey sir I'm
forwarding this to you it's from a
friend I think you should be careful PS
viana loves whips and chains but i don't
doubt our ancestors felt the same way oh
it's one of those string email things he
ever watches the video will bring upon a
bad omen the sender will also encourage
you to send the video to people you know
if you receive it delete them from your
phone don't open the video ok thanks
buddy I'm glad it wasn't the pictures no
ghost professor hasten on the virus note
i was referring to the computer virus
hidden in the 11th essay it was the
bottom let's go to the bottom how
relevant do you feel the philosophy and
sociological themes present oh my god I
can't be all nerdy today it's too early
for this even though it's very dark my
way I never opened my curtains you
bought a good point how would a person
he was cyber nized at an early age
develop properly I would imagine they
would have leave the pitch witchery
gland untouch I know what this is was
the pituitary gland why does that sound
so familiar in my room from when I did
psychology pitch which we picked wit we
overall development in all areas of
human body and psyche would present a
conundrum when sleep or anization is
introduced into the equation what is
like night cyber cyber nization what's
so like injecting a I
to a person maybe iris is the killer oh
happy it is oh happy days why are you
sending me this happy birthday Sarah oh
that's why it was her birthday seven
days without love makes one week who's
this from mingles you've always have a
choice there are three people who
itching to be messaged by you assoc dick
you're on a dating site but she didn't
mess at anyone k for coffee try our new
carpet flavor coffee beans no no great
start to your London 2017 wish list okay
boring boring boring oh this is where
she was staying so extension for days
boom lara single apartment so this is
where she was staying every baby yeah i
think i read them all I know her
deadline ah did she never even give it
in I don't think she even ever gave it
in she was working on it so hard and
then she went missing she never gave it
in ok that's so look at her notes ah
it's her poems there's no place I call
home but warm but it's warm in between
your tone sighs like winter Tigers
listening to goods whispering good night
from nowhere balls
OOP cool iris okay uh what do I do now
what do I do for friends in the
interesting that's a good question
because I I know some stuff oh okay so I
need to find the interesting things and
then I can click and hold on them to see
if I can find anything so I mean the
face thing was quite interesting um wha
para la la is a Walpurgis night in
English it's one of the Dutch to German
names from night so called because of
its eve of the feast day of st. wall
puja ok it's believed to be the night of
the witches meeting based on the text
history it appears that faith is a
practicing Wiccan oh my gosh that's
interesting i would love to have a
friend that interesting what a sourabh
leaving saara bleeds in finding the
truth yeah mm I'm with Sarah um so she
never replied back sir I am how do you
know what is unusual so I was actions
it's unusual because she doesn't text
back obviously through various
calculations of Sarah's SAT basara sorry
keep on saying Sarah Sarah or inactions
in this situation does not matter much a
press personality what is Sarah like
usually her recent behavior shows that
she is suffering from abrupt and
apparent unaccountable chains of moves
possibly due to her relationship issue
but I'm no doctor you're free quieres oh
I think I think I I think I upset him I
think there might be more clues to her
whereabouts I've we looked through her
pictures I believe the calorie is
corrupted would you kindly tap on hold
on the Gallery icon I tried out before
and it said it didn't work
[Music]
please wait while I find what's wrong
thanks iris I will wait uh seems sarah
has kept it locked you will need to find
the passcode to proceed further the hint
is saw his birthday okay ah we know this
cuz she got an email on her birthday oh
happy day so happy days oh happy days
here we go yeah you've sexy a la galerie
boo boo boo boo boo look at the videos
first what did you say he says there's a
strange photo in the gallery okay let's
look at the photos first then ah let's
have a look at the mall food friends
just hanging out with a guy lot is that
Derek that's a ghost buddy that's cool
tattoo yeah I think that's Derek oh they
look some happy it's sad isn't forgot
that face though okay I love guitar I
love that caddy so cute oh she's asleep
hat um you got to find a weird photo
they all look pretty normal to me what's
this it seems that this photo correlates
with a video and a message thread that
sarah has recently deleted yeah retrieve
the data I wish Cirie was this helpful I
have successfully restored the message
thread between Sarah and one of her
contacts jeans are cool okay I'll have a
little look-see does ever look at the
videos so that's that one
there's a little photo shoot cute why is
that guy just like recording them taking
selfies of me or cuddly I would feel a
little bit awkward if I was him but
whatever the advent of vampires but
vampires reside in what the hell so how
is it that no no no thank you oh my god
I'm just think he has a garage step no
she must be doing this on purpose that's
not boyfriend right back up again that's
cute totally freaked me out that no I'm
don't let me watch it again let me go
back thank you um Oh 88 messages
freaking out all right so she's got more
from face and more from James let's read
from James cuz we haven't really heard
much from him yo what are you up to busy
busy anyway I remember you told me you
wanted to start a blog right about our
ghosts and casts research I got
something for you if you're interested
yes there have been reports of people
dying through weird circumstances like
after checking out the weird websites
you answer some stuff and then BAM okay
keep going so yeah they say if you visit
the Site your computer or phone or
whatever will start freaking out pops up
will sup pop ups will start to appear
and the visitor will go insane hang on
let me find the bed
not fan now my whole freaking phone is
going crazy you okay iris are you okay
my controls of our functioning I can't
seem to you the Red Room is connected
what do you mean by Red Room a red room
I have been legend the computer side it
is allegedly a hidden web site or
service in the Deep Web where you can
see and opposite participate in
interactive torture and murder scary
thing is like that actually exists and
then really fix it don't understand
people I was still losing me I found
another message that was recently
deleted this might hold some clues i was
able to restore it for you thanks would
you kindly look at it under the thread
okay so obviously her phone didn't freak
out as soon as she opened up that video
night scary Sarah let's just have a look
look at this one cuz it was or D new
stuff I'm not scared of a party he
didn't have to say that okay so
basically she's like we are going I am
picking you up we are going I need to
have dinner first she lit yourselves
like me just every excuse Under the Sun
like please no don't get me out the
house I need to eat I need to record
videos I need to edit happenings do
stuff skinny pimp or burger lace vagina
what hey where are you why aren't you
picking up I've been calling for 15
minutes right yeah if you don't pick up
i'm leaving you and your lake house
where's the part it is known here oh so
she went to thing on her own and then no
one was there
okay this is freaking creepy no no no
not again please I'm good I don't need
to hear that again hello there is a
Sarah I am I resume i received your
contact from Faith's she told me you're
coming Friday all-party a special
gathering hi RZ yeah I'm supposed to
meet her here what's going on oh so this
is when she was actually there I
apologize but reception here is
undesirably terrible and besides we have
a rule no bone well phones allowed I'm
here to escort you safely to the venue
escort yes my dear it's hard to navigate
in the dark alone it is part of our
experience I'm not sure about this can I
talk to face no you may not I apologize
but like I said phones not allowed she
is safe they're probably drunk already
drunk faith doesn't get drunk how do I
know you're really her friend I have
known as high school really I don't
think she's ever mentioned you I keep a
low profile I'm not sure about this I'm
gonna leave Leave faith will be
disappointed when you didn't show up she
has made reservations for you almost
where to where you are of course how do
you know I am faith told me she was
missing you there I prefer you didn't
come here please I'm almost there please
stop wherever you are don't worry you're
safe I'm going to ring you please pick
up
[Music]
how are you can you hear me I Mexico fly
south
James to help me scared I'm not Sarah
but you say Sarah and I got confused
yeah please text me why didn't we talk
to him ah I didn't talk to it I didn't
even try ki imagine I think it actually
here is that would be a pretty
interesting game we think it here
whether you were talking or not doodle I
am talking what are you doing James what
is that noise James I'm really freaked
out I really didn't think I would be
where are you you've been missing for
almost a day did you go to that party
how did I get this weird ass phone
that's not my phone please tell me you
didn't it's a real bad news am I the
killer did I kill Sarah I'm not sorry
Sarah Sarah Sarah what who are you I'm
not gonna say the first one it sounds
really pretentious Who I am is not
important what matters is that we find
Sahara I guess I have to trust you will
get back to who you are later yeah who
am I tell me who I am I don't know who i
am i'm scared i don't press play as
those who are trying to prepare
themselves for entry into huh oh my god
it's some freaking like tribe travel
Marvel walnuts whatever was all those
things that was cool but that was
definitely from tribe twelve way that
the guy with the mask [ __ ] 12 or was it
was it tried of Marble Hornets and
there was another one dark harvest um I
think there's another one anyway duh I
digress if you don't know what that's
all about it's basically the Slenderman
stuff before the Slender Man games came
about and were terrible hey scary Sarah
hey thought this might interest you
bunch of material for your research by
the way check out their calendar maybe
you should stay in tonight why anyway
let me know what you think Jan damn
what's the day today OOP I don't know
human sacrifice bloody hell male only
male or female there's gross wait what's
the date on the thirtieth of April
thirtieth of April okay so the date is
the 30th of april eight for the 21st to
26 right so it would be April thirtieth
oh yeah the well-polished day blood
animal and or human sacrifice of any age
well that's great why would anyone be
properly into this you cannot touch a
curse binding this case is particularly
for people who have done harm in the
past and is such already known to be a
potential threat the idea is to keep the
person from speaking to or approaching
the one you're trying to protect and
make them feel watched and judge for
their perceptions okay I've got to find
no please do I like in my back oh okay
what does this mean what do you mean
didn't you get the email I sent you
yesterday by the way I'm here where's
the party supposed to be no don't go to
that party it's not good oh [ __ ] I see
them oh my god no text him oh my [ __ ]
god you won't believe this got James let
me help you
oh [ __ ] I think they saw me who owned
him why don't you freaking phone him oh
no nothing is happening okay oh no they
didn't Jesus I was [ __ ] close I'm
hiding behind this I don't know what
this is [ __ ] hear a sound tell me the
things so I can come and get you phone
the cops tell me where you are I'll
phone the cops we will do this together
just chill out James James hello hello
there welcome dear uninvited friend they
got him they got him I apologize for the
sudden urgency I'm about to bestow unto
you what are you talking about say hello
hello to James why don't have to say
hello in it can you say hello oh my god
James I don't want to zoom what is going
on but what's this interesting share
this link with another anyone everyone
or say goodbye to brief acquaintance you
have met two minutes I'm not supposed to
I'm not supposed to share the link but
James don't share the link why are you
doing this Oh what should we share the
link I don't know too that james died
why are you doing this
I don't even know how to share it like
I'll it you don't know how to share I'm
clicking on it and I don't think I can
show it James James darling I want to
help you oh god he's offline I think he
said he's dead I feel like I must iris
is offline everything's offline oh we
killed James it wasn't our fault I
couldn't share the link why did you do
that hello oh my god did you just kill
someone James hello that it's me again I
project not introduce me it's you you're
lomira you're the killer you're the
killer you sick bastard and almost like
love dying without apparent pain
wondering as the world goes by with
caroled smile if anyone else or sense my
crime isn't that it's the poet club or
part of this weird thing I'm one of the
hardy say leaders for the tonight's
ceremony we have met on a very fortunate
night cherish this moment my stranger
friend you just killed someone me kill
never do not take me as a lonely
murderer but you did please do not
misunderstand my intentions why kill
that poor man as I said before I do not
kill you sacrifice and that man was
anything but poor how he was a deceiver
what are you on about what did he do and
let's talk to Siri for I was from a bit
I never think that people die they just
go to the departmental store what okay
well thanks that makes me feel so much
better virus all these choices what do
what do these options mean to you is
this you demonstration to feel free well
can't you see I'm being full
you will never be privy to that
information my young friend nor will you
need it to further your quest what quest
are you talking about I was just Adam
just chillin on my phone you know it's
wanting to Twitter and stuff and then
suddenly all this stuff happens turns
out this isn't my phone and it's a girl
called Sarah who's missing and I don't
know what to do I have told you my name
but not what I do I fear that my age is
somewhat dull me to these simple talk
small talk as you call it it does not
matter much what I do but what's
important for you to know my young
friend is that you like everything else
in the world you have a choice I am here
to offer you that choice didn't offer
James was her choice did you trust me he
made his long ago time is of the essence
not reason what are you offering and now
you understand you must ask the right
questions the choice is simple yet not i
hate talk like that it's like yeah it's
good but it's bad no that doesn't make
sense just tell me would you like to
join us know it's not really i believe
you have the potential it is rare for me
to fight offer this to someone who is
initiated who are why am i joining you
will find out soon enough if you have
your wits about you quickly now yes or
no i can't do this now pity what if life
itself was in the balance say these two
young bhavish and woman and it's sorry
now why do we tell but i found sorry but
I do not it's not my choice sacrifice is
not the act of pure destruction it is
merely transformation like this
perpetual I leave it up to you God
Himself makes these decisions all the
time does he not why not use some of the
work for him or her or it however it is
you see your God Sarah or faith their
names mean nothing to you
other girl is faith but to us they are
what binds them to this flesh and mud
say one of their names and know that it
will be their last breath there was no
sweeter invite than a last breath to
welcome you one passes and never comes
what say you why do you say i love this
oh why me because you have this phone
why why not it's fun it's not fun since
you were here anyway why not choose
everything in life is a choice whether
you join us or not it makes no
difference yes or no sorrow or faith you
have 10 seconds I'm sorry faith but it
was your father she went in the first
place Oh God these pictures are actually
vile like they're pretty good in a bad
way obviously Oh God the deed is done
welcome my child you are indeed of rare
being answer me this why did you choose
faith I wanted to see what you do to I
wanted to see her die it's all
meaningless in the end it may seem
meaningless now but life has much a
meaning as we put into it come now to
these coordinates okay it's a tough
choice but I had to be done as always
you don't think bad of me then that's
all I care sorrow means too much to me
what would happen if I killed Sara it
hurts to see faith go sour new faith for
the longest time I hope face doesn't
mind well she's dead you know so uh yeah
life hurts a lot more than death I guess
that's true
at least I was okay we need to find her
quick hey ho music's playing don't down
down down down with some lovely images
that I really did not want to see thanks
you made this far too bad you won't make
it much father but you know that you
have now become part of something much
larger all will be revealed in due time
but not this incident any last words as
you humans are so fond of leaving them
behind I rescue part of this it was good
it was good but you know um I'm all
struck
oh wow wow wow wow wow it's not that I
don't love our little chats it's just I
don't love them what is that the end
what the hell was the end okay I'm gonna
see what happens if I kill Sarah instead
of face and maybe try and see if I can
actually share that link cuz I was
honestly trying quick i forgot that
happened yeah i'll see you in a second
IAM not James this is james what's going
on hey okay how do i save how do i send
this I want to send it don't share the
link okay one two how do I share the
link there's no way that I'm gonna
remember all that HT no no stop stop
sending me photos ah mayor can I make
can I can't even share it because I
don't have I can't make kamael can make
a male I'm trying what I don't know how
I can't share it I've really don't think
i can share that link today I'm trying
okay so this time I'll just say yes
straight away and then I'll kill Sarah
and see what happens I don't think it's
gonna be happy i think that iris is
going to be very mad at us save sir nope
i'm gonna do faith i'm gonna say faith i
love this i feel so weird pretending
that i like this you have 10 seconds
what if i wait ten nine eight seven six
five four
what I didn't say faith what the
freaking phone did it for me the phone
said faith what what what the phone tick
tick control phone why did you do that
[Music]
what just happened I'm sorry I don't
think I can help you this time why not
you've been doing a great job so far
please carry on maybe I should rephrase
that I don't think I want to help you
this time oh it's cuz I didn't die
didn't save Sarah I am appalled by your
indecision how is it obvious spell it
out this phone belongs to Sarah Sarah
Sarah Sarah therefore I am loyal to
Sarah therefore faith must die I
voluntarily decided to take away your
freedom of choice your free will if I
may say so your indecisiveness would
have caused harm to sour because I
didn't I didn't choose I didn't choose
an option that was why this is
unforgivable I'm sorry any last words
yeah go on uh-huh I lent my dad I think
that is enough from this game I love how
this game was pretty different I've
never played a game that just plays it
through a phone and it's just a totally
new experience but and it was actually
surprisingly creepy those pop-ups on the
phone because your friends you're safe
space right it is personal to you and
when you lose your phone you don't know
who's got it you can kind of freaked out
so for things to kind of hack into your
phone it's so different because you can
kind of imagine it happening to computer
be your phone a little bit different I
thought I was really good let me know
what you thought about the game in
comments below and I might pick it up
pole and see if you like these sorts of
games so please answer the poll now
regarding the giveaway easy SMX are
giving us one of their gaming headsets
for one of you lucky lucky people all
you have to do is go in the link in the
description below subscribe to this
channel and follow both me and easy SMX
on twitter for your chance of getting
the headset giveaway it does look pretty
damn awesome actually I'm not alive it
looks cool also there will be the
discount for the gaming mouse in the
description as well if you're looking
for a new mouse for around Christmas
time anyway thanks for watching and I
will see you in the next video have a
lovely day or evening bye
you